hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
aspects of stoic moral theory is its
emphasis upon fulfilling our duties and
the word that we translate as duty is
Kathy Cohen and Greek and a Fijian in in
Latin the Kiowas uses the translation
for the kind of a con and stoicism made
its way into wrong and when we hear this
term duty or you could think of as an
obligation there are several questions
that come to mind which stoicism is
going to provide an answer to and a
betina's is going to provide an answer
to part in particular so one of them
would be well what is it to actually
have an obligation or of duty more
important and more pressing than that is
you know a question that requires us to
get a bit more specific and that's well
what are in fact my duties and who did
it do I have them towards and how can I
know what they are so that I can fulfill
them the answer that Epictetus is going
to provide us fairly consistently is
that it has to do with roles and
relationships so you know say
is the word that's used for relationship
I don't have it here on the border but
it's not that important what is
important is is this notion that we as
human beings don't begin you know in a
sort of vacuum where we're individuals
first and then only after that come into
contact with other individuals and that
acquired of duties or anything along
those lines we're born into a matrix of
web of relationships and these in their
specifics have to do with us right I am
born as the son of so-and-so but it's
not as if I'm the first son in the world
so the whole relationship of son to
mother or it's a father or brother to
sibling or you know playmate other
playmate these have been around for a
long time and we can come to some sort
of general ideas about what is what is
involved in those sorts of relationships
so what epictetus tells us is that that
means that the person bears the
automotive lamotte's outside and
integrate those reveal a person's duties
so what are the sorts of names that
we're talking about I mentioned some
familial relations husband-wife would be
another example when you have a child
you know being a father being a mother
police a citizen being a member of the
political community being a resident of
a particular town joining a club being a
neighbor you know this term neighbor it
self-care is some some weight with it
why did you behave in that way towards
that person well I thought it was the
right thing for me to do because they're
my neighbor when you ask people you know
why they took out me the obligations
that they did to help out those who they
they live with and they say things
Epictetus would say they are recognizing
what is inherent in their fellow
traveler now we're getting into things
that seem quite contingent right ruler
and subject or you know we don't simply
have to have it be a political ruler and
political subject it's our own in our
home and on in that the one who gives
the orders who arranges things and the
one who follows the orders the one who
obeys finally human being in general
even that tells us how we want to behave
but only if we really think through what
what these involved so each of these
roles has its own specific duties and he
gives you some examples in chapter 10 of
book 2 but he's gonna bring these up
over and over again the most general
what he says you're to begin with a
human being that is one who has no
quality more sauger than moral choice
but keeps everything else subordinate to
into this moral choice itself free from
slavery and subjection so if you
understand yourself in that way that
tells you whether you want to then
behave in this way and not behave in
that way and you want to behave towards
other human beings in a similar basis
you're separated from wild beasts you're
separated from sheep in addition to this
you are a citizen of the world and a
part of it not one of the parts destined
through service but one of the primary
importance for you possess the Faculty
of understanding the divine
administration of the world and
reasoning upon the consequences so you
know he goes on look if you believe this
sort of thing if this is the way you see
things then you're going to behave in
certain ways not only in terms of
yourself but in terms of other people
who are also human beings you are a
citizen of the world you are ready to
act accordingly
he gives you a couple other great
examples he says bear in mind that
you're a son
what is the profession of this character
to treat everything that as his own as
belonging to a spy
to be obedient to him in all things
never to speak television to anyone else
nor to say or do anything that will harm
him to give way to him and everything
until the precedents helping him insofar
as is within his power and you know some
of this maybe we might say culturally
conditioned so that perhaps we don't
want to say I should go along with
everything that my father says but you
know if you are behaving as a child
showing feel not just affection but
figlio piety or in a feeling of a
relationship to the parents there is a
kind of subordination that is going to
take place not now the subordination of
saying oh I don't matter at all but a
subordination of one's own will letting
your parents you know maybe tell the
same story several times without calling
them on it going and help them change
their their tires or rake their leaves
or things along those lines right we can
look at any other rule in a similar way
a my husband well and there's certain
things incumbent upon me as a husband am
ia father there's certain things
incumbent upon me as a father am I going
to be a teacher
well there's certain things I ought to
be doing as a teacher as well likewise
the students you know we could go all
the way down the line with this and you
can read the other examples in section
in in chapter 10 of book 2 I don't need
to go through all of them in chapter 14
he uses two terms that are kind of
important to think of he talks about
relations and he mentions that some of
our natural Fujiko Fujio sorry and some
of them are acquired of the faintest and
so you know this makes sense for us as
well when I decided that I was going to
become a professor which she don't
happened quite a little a long time ago
so long that it almost feels natural
that was actually a chosen thing when I
got married that was a choice
suppose you to say to a certain extent
you have children it's also a choice as
well it's one that creeps up many people
and surprises them right you know but
being a son being a brother or sister
you don't have much choice about that
where you were actually born you know
you can move somewhere else but you
can't really change the fact that you
were born here there and you did belong
to that community so we have all these
complex relations that overlap with each
other that intersect and we can not only
the seed how we ourselves want to behave
in accordance with them we can see other
people that's what this this chart here
is going to come in see our duty is
really to maintain the Faculty of choice
the per wide races that part of us
that's at the core
Epictetus is in accordance with nature
so if we are filling our duties towards
others we are in fact improving upon
ourselves that part of ourselves that is
the Faculty of choice the the highest
part of the human being every human
being hasn't so when we have some sort
of relationship it could be any of these
right we have two people and keeping it
kind of simple because you know we could
have more complex relationships but we
have two people and each of them he has
a role in relation to the other there
could be the same role you know as in
friends with each other although even
friendships are always about each person
getting exactly the same thing from the
other person but there's there's some
sort of role that each of them bears
towards each other and each of them has
their own Faculty of choice they are
free being who can choose how they're
going to act and they do in fact act
towards the other person here's where
the stoic doctrine becomes very
uncompromising it says look you should
focus on your side as I said clean your
side of the street before worrying about
you know what the
course inside looks like focus on your
Faculty of choice if you're a son you
don't have a choice about whether you're
a son but you do have a choice about
whether you fulfil the duties of being a
son that's not going to necessarily make
your parent like you or behave the right
way towards you they could be a scrub
they could be a terrible person and
Epictetus would say that's got nothing
to do with you you can fulfill your
duties in relation to them even if they
are not fulfilling their duties in
relation to you that's their loss
that's the their own damage to
themselves it's not really harming you
if they don't give you to certain things
because they're not harming your faculty
of choice they are not keeping you from
being able to do what you ought to do
now you know what do we say oh they make
me so mad I can't I can't stand being
with them or you know I love to be you
know nice to them but they're not nice
to me it's epictetus I'm saying well
those are kind of cop-outs you actually
can do that if you choose to do it but
you're not choosing to do it and you're
coming up with justifications afterwards
that'll let you keep on thinking that
way
okay people why the other person is
acting like a jerk as well they're not
fulfilling what they got to do he
doesn't really talk so much about you
know the role of good examples but that
might fall into here as well you know
you come to realize oh I haven't been
fulfilling my duties towards this other
person who is fulfilling their duties
towards me maybe you know I would be
better off if I was doing that if I was
using my Faculty of choice in the right
way
so all of this gives us a very not
necessarily clear in a general sense but
a pretty clear enough specific sense
idea about how we want to behave towards
various people in our life
now of course if we're totally mixed up
about what it means to say be a father
or what it means to be a fellow student
then knowing these names is not by
itself going to be enough we needed some
some clarification but stoic philosophy
could could provide that in any case
Epictetus is going to insist that our
roles and relationships reveal our
duties